no podríamos tratar
en esta escuela fundada un año antes de
la independencia de centroamérica
estudiantes de quinto grado aprenden de
la historia de su país
sin un libro de texto obligatorio los
docentes enseñan sobre la conquista y
colonización española episodios que
definieron costa rica
valoramos la llegada a los españoles
pero también valoramos como vivían
construidas poblaciones a partir de ahí
ese encuentro de culturas que nos
permite ser la sociedad que hoy somos
no siempre ha sido así en el pasado
predominó la versión de conquistadores y
colonizadores
y aunque hay avances hay quienes creen
que el sistema educativo puede mejorar
se enseña desde una perspectiva del
conocimiento occidental europeo como
conocimiento universal y en donde poco
se nos enseña también de otras formas de
saberes y de otros conocimientos y otras
culturas y de manera digamos más allá de
un apéndice verdad la exhibición del
bicentenario expone como la historia
oficial en el pasado dejó ausentes a
poblaciones indígenas mestizas y
africanas en la formación de la
identidad nacional dando paso al mito de
la costa rica blanca y diferente a los
países vecinos les debemos a los
muchachos las nuevas generaciones
tengan una historia integral no
solamente fragmentada y en ciertos temas
en donde se visibilicen no solamente los
procesos sino también a los sectores
sociales
es el reto de la costa rica de hoy que
intenta ver hacia atrás con mirada
crítica para plantearse la nación que
quiere ser mañana